what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
ladies and gentlemen of the Rob core if
you're not a member of the Rob core if
you stumbled across this channel
randomly make sure you hit the subscribe
button to become part of the Rob core
you guys know how I get when a story
makes me excited right you guys know how
I feel well this story is amazing
oh my god it's so well written so this
is done by a guy named Karl ballers
right and what this story does is it
basically tells us how it was that
Doctor Doom killed the Marvel Universe
now the reason why I said this is not
Secret Wars 2015 is for a couple reasons
the first is because it's based on the
original secret Wars or at least the
aftermath of the original secret Wars
the other half of this is that when
people think of Doctor Doom destroying
the Marvel Universe they think of Secret
Wars and so I want to make sure that
they didn't believe that was kind of
rehashing secret Wars but this was a
wholly a whole different set of events
here but with Carl ballers what he
initially does when he opens this comic
is he basically picks up with dr. doom
and the Celestials so this is really
cool because dr. doom is literally going
against all of them and we get this
really cool monologue and that's the
greatest thing about the story to be
quite honest that's the best aspect of
this story is that it's all dr. Doom's
inner monologue there's almost no
wording from anybody else there's a few
lines here and there but it's almost
entirely from his perspective but what
he tells us is that he's seen so many
things he's seen you know villains of
the utmost power he's seen beings who
were neither heroes nor villain of
incredible power he's seen young boys
with power to control the stars he's
seen men that can warp the very fabric
of reality but in the end he's not
afraid of any of it and the reason why
is because he possesses a level of power
that's far beyond what anybody else is
in control of right now in addition to
him going against the Celestials where
they immediately attack him it seems as
though they've actually got him on the
ropes
it seems they actually have him defeated
but what we do is we get this back and
forth you know travel through time and
this is one of the things that he does
is one of the things that Carl ballers
does is he jumps back and forth between
the past and the present now previously
in this or I guess in the beginning of
this he had gone through the origin of
Doctor Doom but I've already got videos
on that so if you guys want to know
about the full origin of Doctor Doom as
was written by Ed Brubaker in the books
of doom you're welcome to check out
those videos which you'll find out in
the in the description of this video but
what we can do is kind of skip over that
origin and really just jump to him
becoming Doctor Doom you know and what
we learned is that when Victor Von Doom
stepped into the role of being the head
of Latveria when he basically took over
Latveria when he instigated a coup
against the existing ruler when he
cashed that guy off and took his place
that he began a conquest against a
multitude of superheroes now this is not
a deviation from Marvel's history the
what-if stories are usually deviations
the what-if stories usually break away
from the existing Marvel continuity by
virtue of a series of events but this is
actually just the normal events this is
Doctor Doom going against the Fantastic
Four for the first time this was Doctor
Doom facing off against spider-man this
is Doctor Doom facing off against
against the Avengers and the Inhumans
this is not a new thing but again this
is really just a scenario where he's
showing us his life overall of course we
have the instance where he was
supposedly killed when he basically
taken the power of the Silver Surfer now
what I mean by this is in Fantastic Four
number 57 I think it was dr. doom had
come up with a scheme to basically steal
the powers of the Silver Surfer now this
is what that terrible movie Fantastic
Four rise the Silver Surfer was based on
but in that story this was after the
surfer had been imprisoned of Earth
after basically siding against you
Galactus in the early days of the silver
surfers landscape the way that Marvel
created his solo series was basically by
saying that after we were standing
against Galactus the Galactus had
imprisoned him on earth and that if he
had tried to pass the barrier that
basically surrounded earth that kept him
at bay it would have resulted in the
surfer being destroyed and so because
the surfer was confined to earth Marvel
launched a solo series form that just
showed his adventures on the planet
Earth that's really raw that that comes
from but doctor dooms scheme was to
steal the powers of the Silver Surfer
and steal a surfboard the issue with
this is that eventually the Fantastic
Four tricked him into basically
travelling into into the barrier after
which Doctor Doom was presumed to have
been completely obliterated now his
consciousness survived on his
consciousness existed but what happened
shortly after this in 1984 is Jim
shooter wrote the original secret Wars
now this is where the story shifts this
is where we begin to get into the
what-if alternate reality situation when
we have the
beyonder basically summoned the
superheroes and supervillains of planet
earth to face off against one another
now again because of the fact that I've
done videos on the Beyonder and the
beyonders because I've done videos on a
molecule man Owen Reese you'll find all
that stuff down in the down in the
description so you can go through all
those videos at your leisure and you can
basically learn more about these
stupidly powerful beings then Marvel
Comics many beings that can just bend
all space and reality to do whatever it
is that they want to but in the original
Secret Wars storyline a Doctor Doom had
basically constructed a device that
allowed him to steal the powers of
Galactus and them in turn steal the
powers of the Beyonder now in the
original secret war story the beyonders
consciousness continued to exist in the
body of ulysses klaw who was a being
that was that was composed entirely of
sound and then to be on door basically
struck at Doctor Doom in a moment of
weakness took his power back and then
defeated Doctor Doom in this story that
doesn't happen instead the the mystic
enchantress from Asgard arrives
basically a meet dr. doom and says hey
the beyonders consciousness is still
alive india lyses claw and he's waiting
to strike either you can destroy him or
you can basically just take off and so
dr. doom chooses to take off and the
reason why he does this is because he
says in his mind there was a world to
change there was a lot of work that
needed to be done
and so what we do is we show up with dr.
doom basically arriving on earth and
telling all the inhabitants of Earth
that he's going to fix everything now
the kicker about this is that the
Fantastic Four dead Ben Grimm Johnny
Storm Reed Richards
they're all dead Susan storm is still
alive at the moment but again she's
confined on planet earth as she was in
the original story of course we have
Tony Stark watching the events unfold
and this is a huge shock to them because
this is the worst case scenario Doctor
Doom showing up with limitless power
basically bending the earth to his whim
now because of the fact that Doom is
face-off against the hero so much he
knows exactly what their initial
response is gonna be you know week we as
readers would expect this to write like
we would expect the superheroes to stand
up against Doctor Doom and to say no way
we're not going to live under your
oppression and so he starts making
examples the first thing he does is he
attacks Lokhande and it falls in under
an hour he defeats the entirety of
Wakanda in one hour wipes it off the map
he goes against Atlantis he defeats
Atlantis and less than
less time that it took to defeat Wakanda
you know he goes to the Eternals he goes
to the deviance these beings that have
existed since the dawn of humanity these
eternals having almost godlike power and
the deviants having incredible
technology he goes through and lays
waste to them all from here he turns his
attention to Asgard and he takes out a
scar destroys it now again Carl ballers
is giving us all this stuff in a really
really fast rate he's not giving us a
whole lot of information here to be
honest I would love to see a story that
was a little more in-depth where dr.
doom where it shows us dr. doom taking
on all these different territories
taking on Asgard taking on Atlantis
taking on Black Bolt and the Inhumans
but the reason why I think car ballers
do this is because but not necessarily
to basically blow these things off but
to show us how powerful Doctor Doom is
right now the fact that he can defeat
some of the most formidable groups and
some of the most hittable cities in
minutes you know if not less than an
hour that shows us that none of them can
stand against his power you know that
for him to destroy Asgard for him to
eliminate Odin to wipe out Odin he
oughta kill off Thor to kill off all
these seven heroes that we know so much
about to get rid of them with the
greatest of ease shows just how capable
he is and so from here we basically
switched to Susan storm now again this
is usually a role that would be taken up
by we but because he's dead she's the
only one left they only remember the
Fantastic Four left alive now this also
shows us that despite all these
situations you know despite the fact of
the world is quite literally crumbling
down around these superheroes they still
look to the Fantastic Four as sort of
this last bastion they look to the
Fantastic Four as this rallying point
whereby they can all come together and
try to form some measure of a cohesive
plan and so when they do this it's
literally this massive orchestrated
attack Moon Knight daredevil Hercules
Nick Fury is running the show because
remember Captain America's dead he died
on battleworld in the original secret
war story when Doctor Doom killed them
all so it's really just kind of
whoever's left on earth those
individuals who basically just weren't
powerful enough we've got scarlet which
we've got a handful of others but none
of them can stand against him I mean
he's just laying waste it laying waste
to every last one of them now the kicker
to this the interesting thing about this
is that Tony Stark is also one of the
most intelligent people now for some
reason here with Tony Stark and Doctor
Strange do
doesn't kill them and that's one of the
interesting things about this we would
expect with the kind of power that
Doctor Doom has that he would kill dr.
strange with almost no effort just
because of the fact that while this is
classic Doctor Strange and he is really
powerful he poses a very significant
challenge because of his power in this
this era of dr. strange we've talked
about this and this era of dr. strange
he had a spell for virtually anything
and dr. doom talks about this dr. doom
says that you know for dr. strange to
invoke the various spells that he needs
he basically has to rely on speech and
so what he does is take away his ability
to talk the other half of this is that
because Tony Stark is so intelligent he
could very easily deduce a way to defeat
Doctor Doom and so instead of allowing
Tony Stark to do this dr. doom basically
forces him to succumb to permanent
alcoholism in a sense that he is going
to be perpetually drunk this is kind of
a kicker here because again I would
think that the dude would really just
kill them off this really seems to be
more of a respect thing from Doctor Doom
in the sense that he recognizes how
capable they are but it solves the fact
that Doctor Doom has a greater plan here
Doctor Doom is not doing this for the
sake of just being a dick for lack of a
better word he's got he's got a goal
here his goal is to bring in an
unrivaled era of peace and an
unchallenged era of peace and humanity's
history the thing about this is that you
know the way this is written by Karl
bottlers he basically makes it look as
though the superheroes are the bad guys
here granted Doctor Doom is forcing
peace at the end of a gun but it doesn't
change the fact that peace is what's
going to happen and so the superheroes
are standing against this we can infer
one of two things we can say either the
superheroes are standing against us
because they don't want peace or the
superheroes are standing against this
because they don't want peace at the end
of a gun but the fact remains they're
standing in the way of peace so I create
some really good philosophical arguments
it's like the debate that we've had
multiple times over on this channel we
talked about like civil war
yes Captain America was on the side of
freedom but of what uses freedom to a
society that would use that freedom to
destroy itself and this really seems to
be the stance of Doctor Doom is taking
not only that he also comes to the
realization that if the various aliens
from around the cosmos begin to realize
that the planet Earth is basically
devoid of the most capable superheroes
they will seek to attack it and so to
fix this problem he travels to every
single alien race in the Cosma
and wipes them all out the Shiar the
scrolls the badoon the technarchy the
the brood I mean they're all gone just
totally destroys every last one of them
but from here we see him jump to the
realm of Mephisto now this is kind of a
kicker when it comes to his character is
because you know for a Mephisto he is a
being that will always come back he
literally feeds on the negative energy
the evil the vitriol you know the the
hatred of humanity and it keeps him
alive and so as long as there are human
beings in existence
Mephisto are really just any entity in
existence Mephisto will stay alive even
if he's only in a weakened state based
on you know his connection to that
individual not only that dr. doom also
realizes the power that Mephisto has and
that he's at his most powerful in his
own dimension and so while dr. doom has
the power of the Beyonder here that
allows him to do almost anything he
takes all precautions here he takes no
risks and so what he does is he quite
literally travels the cosmos and
assembles the Infinity Gauntlet
basically bringing all the gems unto
himself and then going against Mephisto
now again his motivation here isn't to
just destroy Mephisto for no reason it's
to gain his mother's soul back to have
his mother's soul free now his mother's
soul being freed is gonna allow her to
go into the afterlife but he essentially
destroys Mephisto physical body and this
again is really just an instance where
Mephisto is going to reform himself but
from here we have him going against the
Celestials you know in this massive
battle and this is really what it was it
was really just the Celestials banding
together in this last battle at the
Alamo you know this last-ditch effort to
destroy Doctor Doom before he could use
his power to basically take over all
things in existence and instead he
destroys every single celestial in the
universe and so after this massive
battle he basically travels back to
earth and what he tells us is that Wood
has different campaigns and because the
battle with the Celestials was so
extreme it took 400 and some like 70
earth years in order for that to happen
and so over the course of those 400
earth years their battle had impacts on
the solar system in and of itself it
changed the rotation of the earth it
changed its position and it ended up
turning the earth into this this it
basically ended up bringing about an ice
age and the result is that most all
beings
all humans that exist in the universe
have been obliterated they've been
totally wiped out there are a few that
are left here and there but they are all
essentially dying and so in a sense
while dr. doom wanted to bring about
peace to Planet Earth he essentially
wiped out humanity in the process do his
own his own rage his own anger and his
own desire for conquest and so what he
does is he basically says okay fine if
this is the case then I will fix this
you know if this is what's going to
happen then I'm going to I'm going to
effectively start everything over again
and so what he does is he uses the power
of the Beyonder to essentially merge all
the energy into himself travel back to
the very beginning of the universe's
origin and travel to what would be the
early days of Galan with this new
universes coming into existence and
essentially join him when the new
universe began to so in effect dr. do
and basically just reset reality using
the power of the Beyonder after wiping
out all life in the universe but with
that being said we're gonna bring this
video to an end I know this one's a
little bit different than the videos
we've done before just because there's
not a lot to run over in terms of Doom's
philosophy but this story was amazing
and I wanted to share it with you guys
so if you guys are new here to come and
she explained make sure you hit the
subscribe button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
drop a like and I will catch you all
later
peace
[Music]